there's something in me that repels
against trying to talk about thousands
of years you know and millions of people
billions of people in tiny little sound
bites but what do you do right okay so
Asian religions and American
transformations Asian religions that's a
pretty big catch-all category isn't the
true that the book is being talked about
our Buddhism and Hinduism what else
could they have talked about but really
don't other than a few mentions here and
there what else do we logged into Asian
religions that's a big one very good
yeah that's probably enough to it to
work with I mean if we have a world
religion class we'd actually spend time
on each of these and we'd you know I
would the way I set up we spent at least
two weeks on Buddhism at least two weeks
on Hinduism here we're going to do it in
30 minutes again just the slice that we
have here in America so we're not going
to get very even good en oh you know
another thing that they do mentioned on
let's just call it Chinese folk religion
you know there's there's a all these
sort of things that are rolled in
together I mean we could also talk about
sound I or you know the sort of new
indigenous North Korean religion that
the North Korean regime was put together
that would qualify as an Asian religion
but this is already you know very big
plastic Buddhism is one that we'd want
to focus on in part because it's one of
the big four world religions and in part
because it's not a religion that is tied
to just one ethnicity Confucianism is
not just tired of Chinese ethnicity and
it was a major role in Korean culture as
well and lesser extent in Japanese but
primarily it's Chinese you can say the
same thing about Taoism of course change
folk religion is while Shinto is largely
you know a Japanese thing sometimes gets
fused in with these others Hinduism is
tied in with India but there's over a
billion people in India now there's a
lot of Indian immigration it's the
third-largest world religion so it does
make sense if we're going to folk
is on two things we're going to focus on
on these two and your book talks more i
would say about buddhism they had about
hinduism they make a distinction very
early on that I think is very useful for
talking about these religions in America
and you could use this for other things
that are being imported as well they
talk about ethnic religions and I think
number two is again exports so when
they're talking about ethnic religions
they mean religions that are actually
tied in with with Google's particular
ethnicity so they get brought to the New
World by Asian immigrants or refugees
and they practiced primarily within
their own communities they use pure land
Buddhism as an example of that most
people who are pure land Buddhists in
the united states are part of an ethnic
community where they married into that
ethnic community and become assimilated
to it so that's part of why you know if
you want to talk about American Buddhism
you don't hear a lot about pure land
Buddhism instead you hear more about
export or elite ones export religions
have their origins in one of the ancient
traditions but they've emerged in New
aggressive forms like Jeff Japan soka
gakkai lives will look at which is
actually considered a new Japanese
religion but you can also lump in with
Buddhism they've broken brought to North
America by missionary minded adherence
and they saw it converts not so much
among ethnic Asians and when we say
agents that's kind of you know I've
pointed this out that's a weird term
because you know people from South Asia
say the Indian subcontinent are
ethnically is different from
from East Asia or Koreans as they are
from Westerners as they are from you
know Middle Easterners pick whoever you
like but we won't but all longer Asia so
you know that's what we do Elite
religions says you could also call the
import our little strains of Buddhism
and Hinduism that attracted considerable
followings among well educated Americans
seeking alternatives to Christianity and
Islam largely in the you know 50 60 70 s
80s so Zen Buddhism would be an example
that a lot of people got into something
that they called Zen some of it was you
know authentic some of it was just sort
of like putting the other things that
random calling it sad which is still
going on by the time that I was you know
starting to look at that religions and
sort of play around with different paths
yeah you know when you hear people
talking about Hollywood Buddhism that's
what they mean that's sort of you know
pick and choose I like these spiritual
practices I suppose you could say that
the contemporary mindfulness stuff which
is sort of like you know Buddhist and
sometimes Hindu meditative practices
stripped of all their religious content
would actually fit under this elite
designation as as well so your book
talks about all three of these is being
important for the history of these
religions in America the ethnic and the
elite are the ones that show up earlier
on the elite happens pretty early in
American history because people like
Emerson and Thoreau Walt Whitman start
getting interested in you know what
people Eastern mysticism and by that
they meant Asian religious texts like in
Hinduism new pianist ads or whatever
they could get their hands on as far as
far as Buddhist texts not to
were available back then they're more
attracted to Hinduism at that time the
world's parliament of religions in
eighteen ninety three BAM played a major
role that was put together by this
Unitarian who wanted to you know like
actually create a forum where Americans
could get introduced to other religions
and so it drew a lot of attention it was
sort of catalyst for people beginning to
study this kind of stuff of your book
also mentions open court publishing and
Paul Harris who published Buddhist texts
in accessible form all that's on an
elite level you know very little that
trickle down to the ordinary person
industry a little bit of the beatniks
you know back in the 50s and 60s because
probably have seen some you know film
references to them or that's been
mentioned in your American history or
literature classes they really didn't
have much influence though larger
American culture they're always a
subculture in terms of ethnic religions
what we have are largely on the west
coast Asians coming in mostly Chinese
some Japanese to work and there was a
lot of restrictive immigration rules put
into place gradually to it's actually
try to keep them out and reduce the
community that was there and your book
talks about some of these these early
temples in San Francisco i'm going to
skip over that a bit then shifts after
mentioning here that buddhism to talking
about buddhism itself so it's kind of
good to have some some conception
there's a lot of diversity among the way
buddhism is actually practice and even
conceived of but there are some things
that most Buddhists are all on the same
page of them one is you know there's
this guy so
otama who becomes the Buddha the
enlightened one and he's in India he is
from not the highest class of people but
the second-highest they called Varna in
traditional Indian society than the q3
of a warrior class his father was
actually the local king and his father
tries to bring them up without any sort
of you know seeing bad things just like
you know a lot of you have kids you're
going to want to shelter them maybe you
guys have been sheltered a bit parents
wanted you know better life for you that
may e ad and so they you know they try
to keep you from heaven and work crappy
jobs or halsted people shelter view you
know try to keep you from seeing people
being mean to each other we're not we
don't do a very good job because you
know we let kids play these violent
video games fully each other but you
know we do a lot of sheltering right his
dad was the ultimate helicopter parents
try to keep them am you know a lot of
resources trying to keep them from
seeing anybody gets sick god forbid
anybody dying it was just you know nice
nice nice all the time um that doesn't
work you can you can try that sort of
thing let sooner or later you're going
to run into some of the things that lead
you to see that life is indeed crappy
what are some of the fundamental things
that we can't avoid that make us sad or
upset so what's been in your experience
so far you guys are pretty young but
yeah that's a big one I mean this is
going to be a downer either you're going
to die pick anybody you like either
you're going to die before they do
they're going to die before you do or
you die at the same time it's
unavoidable over human history the death
rate is one hundred percent you can't
get away from it so that sucks right you
come from a big family that means lots
of baptisms but also lots of funerals
what else what else is not fun
life yeah yeah I mean you can you can
work out all the time and keeping a
healthy and still get ms or you know
have a heart attack or pick whatever
pick whatever you like the heart attack
probably death you get the idea and we
could go down the line with all these
sorts of things there's all sorts of
suffering in life and so it's the Buddha
before you tend to go to casey's a
wandering Hindu wise man and a set
against and i'm going to try that out
yeah this world isn't so hot i'm gonna
see if i can liberate myself away from
this world but by the way another thing
that goes into this for us in the West
we don't we tend not to believe in
reincarnation we believe one shot around
as it so if your life sucks this time at
least it'll be done after it's done in
the Indian subcontinent they believed in
reincarnation so it sucks this time it's
going to suck next time the only way
that you know maybe have it have it not
so bad is to behave in accordance with
the rules and then you might have a less
sucky life at that time and it could get
better better but it's still never going
to be really great even the gods are not
happy and they're at the top of the food
chain they're not perfectly happy so the
Buddhists this moment of enlightenment
then he comes up with what are called
the four noble truths and guaranteed
there is going to be somebody who will
comment on this and say oh you should
have translated it this way or you got
this wrong but I don't care we're going
to put them up here and give out on
paper there's different ways of
translating and parsing these things but
generally most people agree to the first
of all truth is all life is
everyone you know can agree with that
right always involve some suffering and
what makes us suffer that's what takes
us from being a pessimistic you know
whiny sort of thing to actually having
some sort of idea yeah so impermanence
now why does impermanence bother us
exactly so suffering is caused by you
know purse this out different ways
desire or attachment we want things to
be as they are to continue the way they
are fall in love with somebody it's
great you want them to stay the same
they don't stay the same now you can't
stand them but unfortunately you got
yourself married to them or you know
you're engaged or you don't want to
break up with them because XYZ or
something like that right Maris looks
great at first and you realize this
wasn't the place for you or maybe you
know you're pleasantly surprised okay
for that advice in any case notice
that's that you figured out the claws
right if you know the cause you can
start working
you want to end your suffering stop
being attached to things stop having
desires then you're not going to be
disappointed now how easy is that to do
you know let's say you let's say you
accept it when I say and you come to me
dr. Sadler I'm unhappy I said well your
happiness is caused because your
unhappiness is closed because you're too
attached to things just stop being
attached to things oh thanks great now
on fine is that how it works it's not
going to work with anything I don't do
my homework you know until the last
minute I'm going to stop doing that this
semester I said that the way that myself
you know over and over again as a
student and it's just saying it change
anything what do you need to change
things you guys are pretty successful
yeah what were you the second that the
motivation is nice it's good to have it
what motivation have to turn it into yes
so how do you do it he's got this a full
pound and it includes all sorts of
elements right like right living
following certain ethical rules you know
not getting drunk as part of it
manufactured according if you're strict
Buddha's you're not supposed to take any
sort of intoxicating mind-altering
substance mine clouding substance well
that's often observed in breach as we
say it also involves having it to
meditate so meditation is done for
religious purposes within Buddhism it's
not just to like you know clear up here
of your skin or you know be more relaxed
or something like that it's ultimately
to answer the great questions in life
that's why one meditates and there's a
whole you know community which is called
the Sangha that is oriented around this
and the saga consists of basically 2k
of people I monks and nuns who we
actually live this full time and on the
rest of you know the people who are sort
of contributing to their livelihood
getting prayed for by by the monks and
nuns probably taught by them as well but
who can't do this full time but but
can't at least observe the presets and
you know perhaps if you know
reincarnation actual is kind of a nice
thing in putting things in perspective
if you believe in it because if you're
if you're you know not able to be a monk
you can just contribute to a moment
maybe next time around you get to be in
the book then you get to deliberate
right as you know from Western
perspective if you can't have it in this
lifetime then it's no good right so now
how is this actually lived out in
communities here in the United States
your book talks about a few different
major ways
you look also miss important to all of
that about the ultimate origins of these
things Pure Land Buddhism and Zen
Buddhism ultimately have their origin
and chinese buddhism and from there they
go to Japan so it's not technically true
that there you know entirely indigenous
Japanese there were there you know
buddhism have very very strong influence
and long development in China after it
came from India across the Himalayas I'm
and eventually you know it goes to take
that which at that time it's are like
the Wild West they were we think of tech
titans us being like super nice
easygoing they were they were the tough
guys all the time usually the people who
are mission eyes last are the ones who
are the toughest and meanest so that
means and the Mongols got the same sort
of you know thank sort of Buddhism
transmitted to them Pure Land Buddhism
I'm going to go over this very quickly
purely on Buddhism is not so much
centered around meditation as centered
around appealing through prayer and
through offering devotion to Amida
Buddha Amida Buddha is a bodhisattva and
a bodhisattva is a BA who decided after
they could have crossed into you know
like Vince nirvana however you want to
put it to come back to save all other
beings they took a vow not to actually
cross over until they'd save all the
rest of the universe so me the Buddha
creates a Pure Land and so if you do
things right he'll let you in there then
you can actually work out in light and
the reason why your book doesn't tell
you this but the reason why you would
want to do that is it's too distracting
out here in the time of the Buddha it
was okay but there's so many more
distractions he's dying not like 506
after you know it crosses over there's
so many distractions that it's just not
possible for most people so to be
merciful this Bodhisattva created this
perfect land in which there would be no
distractions and you could work on
enlightenment full-time that's
essentially pure land Buddhism and kind
of a nutshell there's a lot more to it
but seven Buddhism is what's more
familiar to a lot of a lot of Americans
and it focuses focuses on meditational
practices instead there are rituals but
many Americans sort of dispense with
them there's two main schools one
focuses on sitting meditation very tough
to do at least in my experience is you
have to sit and you start by counting
your breath don't think about it and so
you start up you know one to get pretty
good at this nope you thought about
something start over and you know you
got to get to ten we've already here to
actually ready to do anything else I
never got past four you know myself when
I tried this sort of thing because my
mind is easily distracted there's also
another sort of tradition within it
which could system using these teaching
parables called Cowen's liked the one
about what is the sound of one hand
clapping a couple of possible answers to
that including one of them being any
case that's that's a mother major
example of Buddhist stuff here so Luke I
is a in some ways more like pure land
Buddhism and that it's less focused on
meditation and more focused on devotion
it's coming from from Nichiren Buddhism
which taught that the sole path to
salvation was this Lotus Sutra which is
very important Buddhist texts and they
do a lot of chanting and
and meditation focused on that and then
finally we talk about Vajrayana or
Tibetan Buddhism not all that bad
Buddhism is actually technically
speaking Vajrayana Buddhism or tantric
Buddhism but your book says that it is
souls will go with that there there's a
couple of the things that are brought in
particularly wound resort hand gestures
that are supposed to cosmic significance
mantras you guys know what a mantra is
it's not something that by the way came
from Tibetan Buddhism something that
came into from from Hinduism originally
mantra is something you say over and
over and over and over again they're
like a chant and then mandalas mandalas
are these circular artworks sometimes
created with sand sometimes you know
tapestries and if you know how they're
set up you're supposed to be able to use
them as a meditational device to
understand the entire members they
created a beautiful mandala shortly
after nine eleven Odyssey on now plating
says Buddhism also exists in a variety
of other forms the United States but
these are primarily focused on ethnic
communities from East and Southeast Asia
which arrived either as immigrants or as
refugees from from war that's probably
enough about Buddhism it was very
fragmentary but how he you need to talk
about Hinduism which
you know our world scale we're just
going my numbers alone is in certain
respects more important Hinduism has
been the dominant religious tradition of
the Indian subcontinent and that's been
a tradition that's been historically one
of the major centers of culture in in
the world and population Hinduism may
actually spread outside of India itself
to you know get to what we call greater
India while it is still kind of a
missionary religion so that's why you
can find Hindu temples for it for
example in Cambodia or in you know some
Indonesian islands because the influence
was spread so far but now it's primarily
an Indian thing like your book points
out there's no one single thing that we
can actually call Hinduism it doesn't
have the kind of unity that say
Christianity despite being spread into a
whole bunch of different denominations
or Judaism or Islam or even Buddhism has
in part because it's a bunch of
different practices and local you know
sex or cults all kind of rolled into one
unified around some grand themes with a
whole literature now if not all of which
everybody reads or acknowledges but some
texts are more central than others so
you know if you look at one person who
is a Hindu as being representative of
Hinduism you may actually get sort of
the skewed or very partial view so like
a book says it has no dateable
beginnings it's an unfounded tradition
with roots and a prehistoric past
largely from the indo-european invasion
of North
India which serves superimposed elements
of traditional indo-european religion
onto a matrix of peoples that were
already there already had practices in
place it's developed in a variety of
directions it has a long lineage of
sacred texts all of which are revered
but not all of which are actually read
or utilized very widely your book talks
in particular about the Gita sometimes
called the song of the Lord which by the
way you can get for free if you want it
is right to the Bhagavad Gita society
and they'll send me a copy missionary
work and this is actually a chapter from
me much much longer epic work called the
Mahabharata and tells this story about
the hero of Juna caught in a situation
and is conversations with with Krishna
who is actually vision in human form
Krishna teaches Arjuna the three
disciplines were yoga's when you hear
this term yoga we often associate yoga
with you know people carrying around
these mats and going to the studio and
chit chat afterwards and namaste maybe
and yogurt smoothie you know together
but really it will give me something
much more yeah that's what we like the
tiny thought those those are physical
exercises that are supposed to actually
be like liberating your body
deliberating your mind from your body
and they've been turned into an exercise
routine for many people really Yoga is
supposed to be something that frees the
soul from the body so there is you know
yoga in the sense of these these
physical routines and if you want to
know more about it read you know read
Patanjali tells you all about this in
the yoga sutras but there's other ways
of doing it to Karma Yoga Karma Yoga
means Ashley's we're like doing your job
for the sake of doing your job right now
your job is to be a student or you know
the son or daughter or something like
that and you can do it for you know
self-interested reasons or you can do it
as an offering to the divine and that
will free another way is through Jana
yoga which is essentially doing indian
philosophy studying the sacred texts and
thinking about them sacred texts would
include things like the Upanishads
there's a lot of other things as well
Vegas another's bhakti yoga bhakti-yoga
bhakti means devotion and this is
actually the way that many Hindu people
practice their religion they're not
doing it so much by going to you know
study philosophy some are doing it
through carbon yo some are getting it
through through Roger over the
subordination of the body to the mind
but many are doing it act actually
through devotion to a guy entering into
a one-on-one relationship with whoever
it is that you're going to
could be Vishnu it could be Shiva it
could be Kali there's a lot of different
possibilities you're all understood as
being God images of God and the way that
you do bhakti is by you know giving
offerings like going to the temple in
bringing flowers if you ever go to an
indian temple in india amazing colors
because any knowledge everything is a
decorated and then people will bring
flowers they bring proof they there are
special meals that are cooked and
offered at home to a statute of the
deity and it's understood that you know
this is this is a way this goes all the
way back to the Vedas and to a you know
ancient indo-european religion that it's
a way of bringing the spiritual into
existence with the physical and the
model for this is you know sort of
welcoming a guest into your home think
about when you when you bring somebody
home for instance you know take somebody
home for Thanksgiving what sort of
things would you do with a guest in your
house keep the house clean not that I
you know I've never thought about that's
that's actually an element of this yeah
that makes great sense that's that's
very smart that's a big part of the
offering of food and drink hospitality
what else there's usually conversation
right you're not just like all right go
over there watch TV I've got stuff to do
you you know you make it a relationship
that's part of what goes on in bhakti is
entering into a relationship with with
the got your book gives you a number of
different sort of examples of things
that most Hindus do believe and they
then try to try to codify them into kind
of Adak read the existence of one
supreme being an endless cycle of
creations preservation and dissolution
the seeking of milk shop or liberation
from the cycle karma meeting the wanted
cause of the fact determining where you
know you're going to be the next time
around if you haven't gotten off the
wheel for you know for example for many
traditional Indians to be born here in
America means you did something wrong in
previous life because you know you if
you done better you'd have been born in
India where you actually could have you
know been exposed to a proper religious
upbringing and had some ideas about how
to live your life you know if you're
born in a bad situation to probably did
something if you're born in a good
situation probably did good stuff in a
previous life but don't expect that
that's going to carry you over in this
life to the next life you better act
right in this life you know and so
there's a whole sort of ethics built
into this notion of reincarnation
providing worship to divine beings at
the temple in the home who have followed
a spiritual master the pursuit of
non-violence ahimsa and here's something
else is kind of interesting about
Hinduism a recognition that spiritual
truth is to be found in other venues
other religions not only Hinduism that's
not the case for all Hindus there are
what we call Hindu fundamentalists who
don't see that now your book also then
talks about something that's really
interesting how do you live this out in
America one of the central aspects of
this is the building of the temples
they says the defining acted the
emergence of an American Hinduism has
most likely been that of temple building
why well it's the you know the temple is
like a church or a mosque or a synagogue
it's a place where you're not just an
individual or a family that practices
you are part of a community and again as
with American Islam or American Buddhism
Cueto often this means a mixing of
ethnicities not everybody who's India
thinks of themselves just as Indian it's
usually wearing from an India what
language do you speak you know what
would what occupational group do you
come from so building a temple like they
say is not simply the erection of a
house of worship and an act of
reestablishing a relationship with
people with tradition establishing new
rules now that the old ones have been
forsaken but not abandoned your book
talks about a few different examples
Hinduism in America particular groups
with the elite religion we could talk
about Vedanta which is they actually
Hindu philosophy right and most people
are not studying philosophy that's not
how most people do their religious life
right transcendental meditation which
that was a big thing in the 60s the 70s
it is pretty much you know go on is any
sort of important force today but it was
an adaptation of yogic meditation
techniques India has also contributed
export religions the one that probably
you might actually had some contact with
our the the Hari Krishna's or the
International Society for Krishna
consciousness Krishna is an avatar of
Vishnu and you know legs of bhakti
is about in a warship devotional
relationship with God and they're a
group that carried a lot of sort of
evangelization mostly among white
Americans and Europeans and attracted
them to become Krishna worshipers so
this involves you know food offerings
ritual dancing ritual singing where you
might have seen them would have been at
places like airports because it used to
be now now after you know 911 it's very
difficult to do this sort of thing but
it used to be that you can basically you
go to the gate airports when I was your
age I used to go you know like pick up
you know friends or girlfriends and
you'd like to meet them at the gate and
nobody questioned you well there'd be
these uh Hari Krishna's they'd be
dancing around and drumming and singing
and looking for for you know offerings
from people that was their form of
evangelization airports were seen as
like a perfect place to do this because
people are coming and going right they'd
give up give up tracks so that's that's
probably a good place to end